and now on book TV the parents of the
late Trayvon Martin Sybrina Fulton and
Tracy Martin discussed their son's life
and death
and their experiences with the judicial
system in their book rest in power the
enduring life of Trayvon Martin they're
joined in conversation by Washington
Post's national reporter Wesley Lowery
author of they can't kill us all
Ferguson Baltimore and a new era in
America's racial justice movement this
weekend marks the fifth anniversary of
Trayvon Martin's death
thank you guys both again for joining me
today to talk about the book you wrote
about both the death and the life of
your son i Trayvon Martin I wanted to
start off by you know first noting it's
been it's been five years it's almost
hard to believe it both feels longer
than that and shorter than that what do
you guys what are you thinking about now
five years later as you revisit the life
and also these traumatic events that
happened you know to your family five
years ago um each year when his birthday
comes around which was February 5th
which was Sunday it just reminds us of
what we're missing out on we didn't get
a chance to watch him graduate from high
school or see him go off to college or
go to the prom or things like that and
so I think you know I think all the time
about how many hits he would have had
and who he would have married and things
like that so at 22 is fairly young but
he would have been graduating from
college like his brother did so
definitely dress I just think about all
the good times that we shared with them
and knowing that those memories can't be
taken away from us we definitely as
parents you always want to see your
children do something productive in life
and so we definitely would would have
been hoping for college another college
graduate from our kids and going on just
to see his life progress seeing him
become a man
seeing him raise his own family and
things of that nature so those are the
things that we think about all the time
the things that we miss of course no
Sabrina you opened the book by talking
about the question you remember getting
so many times who was Trayvon Martin who
was Trayvon measure and Martin I mean
one things I really enjoyed about the
book was learning more little details
about and out how he was raised what his
interests were what what do you think
you know there's so much has been
written and said about your son
he tells just a little bit I know you've
done it a million times even say so in
the book but tell us a little bit more
about who Trayvon was what we missed
when we were digging through all the
school records and whatnot
what tell us about the son Union well I
that's the reason one of the reasons why
we wrote the book because we wanted our
point of view we wanted the parents
point of view a lot of times from the
books that were written they didn't even
know Trayvon they didn't even know who
he was and so we want to put the name
with the person with a teenager with an
average teenager and so um Trayvon was
very affectionate he didn't care where
um he was he could be it could have been
in the grocery store it could have been
at his school at the park if he wanted a
hug and a kiss he got a hug and a kiss
and he didn't mind like people who was
around him you know like a lot of times
when they get when they little we always
kissed them whether they girls are boys
as a mom we always kissed them but as he
got older it didn't faze him that people
were around and so he was very
affectionate he felt that he wanted to
do everything for me that's where the
name cupcake came from but he did
everything for me he was a good kid he
uh he uh he just was a good person to be
around kind of funny you know but just
you know you know just really
affectionate of course one things I
think you guys do so well in this book
is walking through what this experience
must be for parents and we unfortunately
have a long list of names cases that
have boiled up that have gone national
that people talk about and one of the
things as a reporter who covers those
very often I having built relationships
with many families I always feel like
the coverage misses some of what that
experience must be to be there that
first day caught making the phone calls
realizing Trayvon's not there that
morning to to get the phone calling your
car as you've been working figuring out
what's happening what do you think I
mean I think that you both tell the
story of Trayvon Martin
you also tell the story of what it is
like to be a grieving parent and one
thing I noticed when you when you talk
about this you talk about gun violence
broadly right not not just those who've
been killed by police not just those
who've killed by vigilantes also I know
in your both circle of mothers and other
groups it's people who've been killed by
street gun violence and that's type of
thing can you talk about at you all now
being some of the kind of elder
statesmen unfortunately of this type of
group of parents
what it's like both what it was like for
you all as well as what you hear from
other parents this unique experience of
losing a son or daughter this way I
think is very challenging but one thing
you find out through a traumatic
experience with other other parents that
have lost children to senseless gun
violence or any any type of violence you
find out how strong people are you we we
as parents we're not built to bury our
children and so to bury your child it
really does something to you emotionally
we know that we all have to we all we
all die we all will die but it's just
the fact that you that we as parents we
invested 17 years and in the Trayvon and
and not to see that life go progress any
further is really hurtful but in
conversation with other parents you I
personally always tell them that I know
what you're going through but I don't
understand you're hurt because each
parent has a different relationship with
their child and so and for instance Mike
Brown I understand what his parents are
going through but I don't understand
their hurt because I don't I don't know
the relationship that they had with
Michael so I know the relationship I had
with Trayvon I know the relationship
Sabrina had with Trayvon and so I
understand hurt hurt but we we it's a
say it's a fraternity so to speak that
no one really wants to be a part of we
didn't sign up for this but but since
it's been thrust on us we understand
that there's a bigger picture there's
something more important than just the
death of our son there are other lives
out there that we're we're trying to
impact that we're trying to save and so
just being the elder statesman so to
speak I think that we've we've taken on
the role and we understand the role of
what it is and how it is to assist other
families
one thing I thought that was fascinating
in this book and in part was the
structure of how it was written going
one chapter for Sabrina one chapter by
Tracy kind of going back and forth
chronologically telling the story
together and as I read this I read the
story of Trayvon Martin or the story of
his death but I also read the story of
two partners two people who were working
together even though they weren't
married still at the time but who were
partners in raising children together
and who were while still functionally
close brought even further back together
can you talk a little bit about one the
the relationship the two of you all had
in terms of being the lead spokespeople
for your son both in the pursuit of
justice and since then with the work
you're doing with the foundation and
whatnot and what that was like to have
you know to have this bond together as
the parents of this child I think the
common focus that we we have was the
children and so we knew that even though
our relationship didn't work out that we
still had to have a relationship with
the children and so we just stayed
focused on just being parents and so it
made it easy for us to raise them
because we wasn't fighting back and
forth you know we kind of got along like
okay you pick up this time and I didn't
have a really you'll have a problem with
that and he didn't have a problem with
picking them up so it kind of worked out
and you know a lot of people think it's
so strange that we get along so well
because I guess a lot of divorce couples
don't get along and so um I think we've
always just been civilized to each other
you know we don't always get along you
know but for the most part you know we
come together for the the betterment of
the kids and so we managed to do that in
spite of what we were going through we
decided that you know that was best for
their children
of course Sabrina when Trayvon was first
killed you were still up in Miami right
and and Tracy you were down in Sanford
at the time and went one passage I
wanted to note was this piece from the
book where you first arrived in Sanford
Florida I thought it was a very kind of
telling but also
kind of emotional moment you know there
was this you talk in the book about not
even necessarily wanting to go not
knowing if he wanted to go being
heartbroken not be you know just and you
can imagine any month II don't I read
this I think of my own mother or what
and what what she would be going through
and what she would be thinking and I
just remember being struck by this
passage as you're pulling into the the
complex where Trayvon Martin was killed
we turned a corner and for the first
time I could see the community where my
son was killed the retreat was a nice
clean development but besides the big
black entrance gate I saw something that
shook me a memorial we had to look twice
to see that it was a memorial for my son
there were footballs teddy bears signs
cards and letters with the name Trayvon
on them everything in tribute to my
angel that memorial that outpouring from
strangers touched me deeply in a way
that place did not their retreat was the
crime scene but the memorial was a gift
strangers telling us through these cards
and small tokens of childhood that they
knew that the body on the ground was a
boy a human a life and that his killing
wouldn't be forgotten was that the
moment you realized that other people
were going through this grief with you
and and what did it feel like to see
both through this memorial and then as
you go through the rallies the activism
to see the support you start gaining
from from the nation um I think that was
the first public sign that on people
were supporting us but it didn't give me
a gauge at how many people were in
support of us that did touch me because
I wasn't expecting it and so to pull in
the gate and just to see the memorial it
just reminded me that this is the the
spot this is the area you know this is
the surroundings that he was he was in
because I had never been there but I
think what really hit me hard too was in
New York when we were at the million
hoodie rally is when we actually saw the
amount of people that came out to
support us the memorial touched my heart
but the the million hoody rally touch
not only my heart but my mind and it
made me you know think about how many
other people this happened to and nobody
heard about their name and so I think
that the name Trayvon Martin represents
not just who Trayvon Martin was but all
young black and brown boys and and some
girls as well that have been killed and
nobody is being held accountable and so
it it definitely was an important part
of the movement it was important part of
the journey and I just have so much
respect for people that supported us
of course Tracy you right at one point
that strangers descended on our cause
like angels and what was fascinating for
me also in addition to kind of this
inside view of what this must be like as
a parent was to also see so many of the
kind of players who come into into play
over time right your first conversation
is with you know what whether it be
Jasmine Rand or Natalie Jackson or Ben
Crump the Ryan Jew listen so I know from
from working with many of these cases or
the Michael school mix who I know as
well you talked a little bit about I
think very often for a casual viewer a
casual reader someone who just knows the
name Trayvon Martin knows the case you
know kind of loosely they don't
necessarily see all of the pieces that
come into play in terms of they see it
rally but they don't necessarily know
who was involved they they wonder how
does Ben Crump and with you all how does
the fact can you talk a little bit about
some of these people who perhaps you
know well well you guys are rightfully
the faces of your sons like I see these
other people who played roles in in kind
of turning what could have been the
death of a young man that people didn't
know about to a name that still rings
out across the nation I think we all a
lot I think we owe majority of the the
majority of the recognition that the
name Trayvon Martin received from a
family member whose name is Patricia
Jones
because without Patricia we wouldn't
have been in contact with attorney
who definitely played a very very
important role in bringing justice or
bringing a light to our case and and so
when I first talked to attorney Crump
hee hee automatically he told me that
there would be an arrest when I
explained the case to him that Trayvon
was killed were walking home with with a
can of iced tea and skittles and the
first thing he said that there would be
an arrest and I continued to call him
and call him and call him and he finally
he finally answered the phone in and
he's I told him I said they hadn't made
an arrest yet and so attorney Crump
basically stopped what he was doing and
immediately started started putting
things in the place the first the first
lawyer that we actually saw was Jasmine
Tran who came down came down those
Sabrina's place and we had a
conversation with her and it was strange
when we met Jasmine because we were you
know here it is our son was killed by a
nun and black and and so the first
person that walks into the house to
represent the family is a white woman
and so you know it kind of kind of like
threw me for a minute and then she
opened her mouth her conversation began
as well do everything that we can to
assist you guys and that attorney Crump
would be coming down and speaking with
us and so Jasmine played an important
part
terney parks and Crump both played a
huge part they still play a huge part in
the things that we do and Ryan Jolson he
he also man Ryan played a huge part man
Ryan yeah
definitely Natalie Jackson uh and and
with all these all those components
working together and they were working
their day out and and Natalie had inside
scoops with the newsroom that really
just helped us out and and and and in a
big wait and so those who definitely
were major major components to to to our
strategy to get justice to getting the
rest
so what also kinda struck me was the way
you almost had to campaign for justice
and in various different phases of this
campaign and I think it's easy to
consolidate it all together now years
later but walking through the book we
see kind of campaign after campaign
starting frankly with the release of
these 9-1-1 tapes in the first place
even before any you guys were certainly
asking why has this man not been
arrested but one of the first big things
that attorney Crump pushes for and you
all are pushing for publicly is let's
release these tapes let's hear this
interaction well what was that like and
what was going through your heads at
this moment in time where you know
you've been played the tape one time
quickly in the initial interview but the
public hasn't heard these it and the
whole family hasn't heard them yet that
moment where you're trying to figure out
there's some evidence that might help us
decode what happened to our son why
won't they give it to us what were you
thinking during that in the first few
days and weeks as you're trying to get
tonight one one tape so for the most
part we when we realized that they
weren't going to give us the 9-1-1 tapes
we automatically just went to our notion
was that there's a cover-up that there's
something going on that because they
were fighting so hard not to release the
tapes and and all we were saying is
release the tapes let the public hear it
and there was just so much it was so
much it was a so much of a fight we had
to file an injunction to get the the
tapes release and and the mayor of
Sanford he finally decided to release
the tapes but just knowing that it was a
fight to get the tapes released we knew
that there was something on those tapes
that that kind of characterized what
happened
night Sabrina you you write about that
first time here at the Sanford a a
central city hall listening to these
tapes of the 911 callers who were
witnesses to the altercation and you
write about one that the pain and
difficulty of listening to them yourself
but but one thing that struck me was the
mayor coming out to you afterwards and
and providing you some comfort and any
write that he'd heard these tapes as a
father would you talk a little bit about
what your relationship was with some of
the whether it be elected officials even
policing officials I think there's an
assumption sometimes that there must be
a full adversarial relationship and
there are certainly times were you all
in your attorneys were calling for
certain actions and vice versa
but I was also struck by these kind of
moments of humanity where people
wouldn't necessarily assume the mayor of
Sanford to be an ally of yours or a
comforter of yours but there was this
moment of humanity between the two of
you at least I think that during the
whole time that a lot of people in
Sanford were torn between if they stand
up for their community or they support
what's right and I think with the mayor
his humane side
peeped out and even though he seemed to
be this strong you know governed by the
governing governing body for Sanford
he's still a father and and he probably
thought about Trayvon being his own son
and so that touched him a great deal but
not only him there were also when we
went to the trial there were also court
deputies and police officers that were
there that would tell us that they
they're in support of us you know so it
was like you know they were torn between
what side they had to stand on and we
want people to stand on the right side
we want people to see Trayvon as an
unarmed 17 year old which are the facts
you know Trayvon wasn't committing any
crime and we say that all the time he
wasn't carrying a
a weapon even though the defense team
brought in this slab of concrete and
said that this was the weapon that he
used and what I mean that's just simply
ridiculous and then you know just where
everything that went on I think that you
know it made people want to choose a
side but I think if you look at the
facts
you know Trayvon wasn't paying attention
to his surroundings he was on the
telephone and it's clear that the the
killer of Trayvon was asked not to
pursue him don't follow him if are you
following him he said yes but you can
hear he was clearly following him and
and and at some point in time Trayvon
even ran and and this person just ran
after him so to me I would feel like I'm
being stalked you know I would feel like
why are you following me what what is it
about me that you're following me and so
for some digits for some time we we
thought that it was the hoodie but we
clearly know in hindsight that was
absolutely because the color of his skin
and so even though we couldn't they
couldn't bring it in at the trial
we know that it's clear and that's what
happened and so you know it sends a bad
message to our young our young men and
women that you can't even walk down the
street on the telephone you don't know
whether to walk fast or walk slow you
don't know you know whether you should
speak or not speak it's just so many
things that they have to go through and
they don't feel safe in their own
community in their own country well that
was you write about this and there's
this moment of the head of Geraldo
Rivera tweet where he's saying the
hoodie is the problem if he only had
been wearing a hoodie he wouldn't have
been killed and there's a line where you
talk about well he could have taken his
hoodie off but he couldn't have taken
his skin off I think that that was one
of the things that felt so compelling
about this story I think where so many
people identified with it at the time I
was in college still and I remember
sitting at my college newspaper reading
these columns Charles blows column or
articles being written about this and
thinking to myself now I grew up in the
suburbs of Cleveland thinking to myself
how many times in the middle of the
night was I
walking around going to the corner store
we're always wearing a hoodie constantly
and how easily could this have happened
you all talk about this I've heard the
parents of Jordan Davis talk about this
as well this idea that there's the sin
of black skin that that our children can
do everything right and that in this
instance there may still be this person
who is who is lurking and who was going
to be suspicious of them kind of
famously
the judge ruled in the trial that racial
profiling the where racial profiling
couldn't be used but profiling could be
and you both talked about the book there
kind of evolution of you're thinking how
initially you both say well this isn't
really is this really a race thing how
does race factor in some kind of
discomfort at the very beginning even
with people using the kind of the terms
race but by the end and again I really
appreciate this because you walk us
through your thinking as you were seeing
in the parts of this case come together
and you start to say what else could it
have been now at the hindsight of these
years and with you know a steady kind of
drumbeat additional names being at it
what role do you think race played in
the death of your son they could played
a major role and for one and it goes
back to the 9-1-1 tapes and and they
tried to they're saying that it was some
one thing that he said and we realized
it was something else that that the
killer of our son was saying on the
tapes and he just had the perception
that all all black and brown young men
were up to no good
he even said it and it's to end the
tapes this guy is up to no good
how can you be able to no good and
you're simply just walking home from the
store and so we definitely knew that
race played a part you know we wanted it
we did we want this to be a issue a case
where it was just an unjust killing and
and and so we tried to we tried to look
at it from a dual dual lens and say
there may be race didn't play a part but
the further we went along in the trial
and we saw we saw it come out in the
juror juror pool selection we saw it
come out in some of the things that the
defense attorneys were saying and so by
the end of the trial we definitely knew
that it was it was about race and and
race played a huge part in our son's
death and and anybody who says that race
didn't play a part didn't even you know
didn't didn't watch the trial we your
your black men as well right and and I
think that there's an experience very
often when black men and also black my
movie talk about their experience as
white audiences very often just just
don't get it they can't understand what
it's like to have been follow around in
a store or to feel kind of you know
stocked in this way by someone people to
feel suspicious of you just by your
presence what was you know had you and
Trayvon had conversations about that as
he was coming up and and what were your
feelings and again you were here you
were watching kind of your son go
through this thing even after his death
being cast in a certain way stereotyped
in certain ways what were your feelings
is kind of a black man looking at your
son being cast this way well it was
hurtful knowing that you know we we are
four or five hundred years eliminated
from slavery and just it just the
thought of how people think about us you
know how how how they think that we are
less than than 100 percent human and
it's crazy just to know that I work with
you I pay the same taxes that you pay I
shop at the same stores you shop at but
your perception of me is that I'm not
good enough to stand in line with you
and so it's very hurtful especially when
you have us a 17 year old that you know
that you've invested a lot in and that
you've taught him everything you know
do's and don'ts and the laws of this
land but just to have a person that that
don't know him make comments about him
and and and sort of demoralize him it
was hurtful but at the same time we know
that the things that they were saying
weren't true because we knew who he was
as a not only as our son but just as an
african-american young young
and we knew who he was so the second
phase if the first phase was Trayvon's
death and then the push for the 9-1-1
tapes after the tapes were out the
second push now is for arrest george
zimmerman right this idea of this man
has has killed your son and he's been
allowed to go sleep in his own bed and
and be free this this ongoing question
of are they gonna file any charges is
he's gonna go to a grand jury and die
there or they're gonna bring in a
special prosecutor you just walked
through a little bit what that second
set of push was and again with this idea
that here you are the parents of a young
man who's been killed essentially having
to campaign for justice for your child
well the whole time as grieving parents
that was our focus our focus was that
was to try to get justice for Trayvon
and so all of these obstacles were
placed in the in our path you know I
mean what parent do you know that has a
17 year old that if something happens to
them they wouldn't want answers
so we wasn't asking for anything that
any other parent would not have wanted
for their own child and so but people
don't see that you know a lot of times
people don't see things because they're
not going through those things they'd
rather sit behind a computer or complain
about something that they really don't
know anything about but I just feel like
everything was a struggle getting the
information about what happened was a
struggle but it was only two people that
were actually there and one of them is
dead and so the the other person is
unbelievable you cannot believe what
this person says because of course they
want to stay out of jail and so we had
to a challenge with getting answers from
the Sanford Police Department Tracy had
to struggle with the men examiners just
to get the body released we had to you
know we had to try to work with the the
state of Florida to try to get them to
pursue the case even harder once the
special prosecutor was assigned to the
case and it was just a constant struggle
on the arrest was a struggle I mean
everything that we we've gone through
was a complete struggle and this was
during the time we were grieving because
this happened fairly soon after he was
shot and killed and so while we were
trying to get answers all of these
things played a part but I think the
most important thing that did take place
was the fact that we had good legal
representation from parks and Crump's
office that gave us the advice and the
guidance that we need it because we
didn't know anything about this and we
didn't know what to do next and it we we
kind of had a guideline to kind of show
us what we needed to do and then some
things we we you know probably didn't
listen to them on and want it to do
because we were so passionate about
trying to get justice for Trayvon what
was the feeling when when the charges
are finally announced you know this this
you've gone through this whole period of
time so quickly as you say where you
find out your son has been killed you
find out the person who killed him has
not been arrested you fight for the
tapes you fight for an arrest you get a
special prosecutor you have to do what
the fight is gonna be a grand jury
what's gonna happen and then finally
this press conference has been called
and this man who killed her son is going
to face these charges what what is that
feeling like oh it was a good feeling
knowing that there would be an arrest
and at that and at that particular time
we still have faith in the Florida
judicial system mm-hmm because they did
make an arrest I don't think if I had
had it not been for the special
prosecutor I don't think an arrest would
have been made had it went to the grand
jury it would have died there and so
when when the announcement came that
they would be arresting them on
second-degree murder charges he although
we thought the charges should have been
first-degree the arrest was made and we
were at a place where we we were hopeful
but but that was just an arrest and that
was just one part of the process of
course we were looking for
conviction had it been the issue on the
other foot had Trayvon would have been
28 years old and killed a 17 year old
white white young man we know that there
would have been an arrest without going
through all the loopholes that we went
through there would have been an arrest
that night that kid would have went to
the morgue and Trayvon would have went
to someone's prison we know that for
sure
and that's just that's just how the
justice system works that's just you
know it's it's it's a no-doubter when it
comes to minorities and then it's it's
let's give the benefit of the doubt to
the killer instead of the victim when it
comes to other others killing minorities
and so the the the charges being being
the announcement of the charges it was
huge for us and as I said we were still
hopeful when did when did you lose some
of that hope it was interesting one of
the things I enjoyed in this book
enjoyed I have no right word because it
was very taxing to read through the
experience of two parents sitting every
day in the trial you find out if the
person who's killed their son is going
to jail it and I appreciate you sharing
with us the notes you had essentially
your reactions in real time two pieces
of dialogue in the trial and the
transcripts and and you both present
specific things sometimes that either
graded at you or moments where you said
I don't know what you know I wish that
officer would have been asked more
specifically about about this on the
officer who the initial interview of
George Zimmerman and this idea that well
you said that you thought he could get
charged with manslaughter and now maybe
he's not being pressed on that I
remember the notes from when Rachel the
the last young lady to speak with
Trayvon before his death and this this
kind of interview this cross-examination
that goes for hours and hours and you
can see her getting frustrated and get
what was it like to be in that courtroom
with both the person who killed your son
as well as some support you right
about the Ministry of presence the
ministers who were sitting behind you
and around you and that feeling and was
there a moment where it felt like we've
come so close to achieving justice we
got this person charged who perhaps was
not otherwise was there a moment when
you knew or felt that he's going to get
off on this it's not good he's not going
to be convicted there there were times
that was my first trial and so I don't I
didn't I'm not familiar with with trials
I mean I just don't know the process and
so there were times that I listened and
I noticed that when you have a private
attorney they can say and they do almost
anything but we had the state of Florida
that was prosecuting the case and they
do things by the book and I don't even
think people paid attention to that but
me sitting there you know just
witnessing the whole thing it seemed
that they were able to do almost
anything and say almost anything but
they the state of Florida's office had
like a process they had like procedures
that they had to follow like okay these
are the parameters that they would stay
in and they wouldn't do anything that
was outside of that and so I don't know
I don't know if it's if it has anything
to do with how much money you have and
and who prosecutes the case you know but
I know that it just seems so unfair just
sitting there just just listening to
everything and one of the things that
Tracy always brings out is that the fact
that they never bought in a character
any character witnesses for Trayvon you
know so nobody got a chance to know who
he really was
we only listened to the defense painting
a picture of who this person was that
was shot and killed somebody they had
never saw before somebody they had never
met and they just simply didn't know
their job was to get their client off
and that's what they did by any means
necessary they didn't really care about
who he was they didn't really care about
the parents but sometimes you have to be
careful what you do especially when you
have
own children murder one thing you guys
talk about is this intense media focus
and these leaks that were coming all of
a sudden the media has Trayvon school
records which should be sealed because
he's a juvenile all of a sudden there's
there's questions when did they're
running up to you it wasn't he on drugs
what's going on what did it feel like I
couldn't remember a time where all of a
sudden someone discovered his Twitter
page and so there's all these questions
about you know and as someone again at
the time I was a college student I had
two younger brothers who were in middle
school in high school at the time I know
what that Twitter page just looked like
and what did it feel like it felt almost
as if at times Trayvon was on trial at
least in the public right you know that
that we're having this public grapple
with but was he was he a thug or was he
an angel did he deserve it did he know
what did that feel like to watch your
son kind of go through this publicly and
have all these people who don't know him
talking about him in this way I'm gonna
say that we never put proclaim Trayvon
to be an angel until after his death
that I want to make that clear we always
say that he was an average teenager
average teenagers have their ups and
downs there they have their good days
and the bad days they have times when
they are hanging with the bad crowd and
they have times where they're hanging
with their family and so those stories
that we heard were kind of hit and miss
some things were like a little true and
some of them were not true even at all
you know they had pictures floating
around of Trayvon and it wasn't even him
and you know it's just you know it's
it's an upsetting to have to go through
that as a parent in and just to listen
to all the negative things people said
but the reason why all of that was say
it was to try to justify why somebody
shot and killed an unarmed teenager you
cannot justify that I don't care what he
did I don't care if he stole something
out of the store I don't care if he
smoked weed or mayor or whatever I don't
care I don't care that he was suspended
from school he was my son
and I loved him dearly and he did not
deserve to die he did not deserve to die
and that's what people don't understand
regardless of
who he was and his ups and downs and his
mistakes that we all make them so
nobody's perfect so it's easy for
somebody to sit back and say well he did
this oh he got suspended from school so
because you get suspended from school
you should be shot and killed no where
does that come from and that's because
this country takes death and shooting
and killing so nonchalantly we have to
be more mindful of a death and how many
people that person may affect just
because of that senseless gun violence
that senseless act because it didn't
have to happen mm-hmm now we know how
the trial
turns out we know that there is no
conviction well what was that like to
have now set you've been campaigning for
justice for your son for a year year and
a half and it felt like a fight every
step of the way what what is that
feeling you guys write about how you
weren't even there anymore when the when
the announcement comes the unit you said
we had to go home and drove back and are
sitting or watching I believe in
Sabrina's sisters for the announcement
what was going through your head I mean
I know you all had some time before you
made public statements but what were you
thinking in those moments as you while
you may have suspected this was what was
going to happen now knew this at least
this part of it is closed well we knew
once we left the courtroom we knew that
it wasn't gonna be a conviction and so
we put our put our minds together and
said that even though there won't be a
conviction we won't let the acquittal
define who our son was and so we didn't
want everybody to remember Trayvon how
he died we wanted him to remember who he
was and so when we let I think we want
once we left that courtroom we knew for
a fact that we had a uphill battle and
that in order for us to continue to stay
in the battle that we would we would
have
work hard more harder than we ever had
to work to keep his name in the
forefront to Portland justices that that
that are plaguing our communities and so
we knew it we had our work cut out for
us and and we vowed to continue to fight
for justice not only for Trayvon but for
other kids and so I think when we left
that courtroom we left with a sense of
that we knew that we were we were
discouraged but we knew in order to in
order to navigate through the
discouragement
that we had to stay strong remain strong
and and focus on this not just being
about Trayvon that this is about
everybody else kids you know all the
other kids that are getting taken away
from us and so I just think that it made
us realize that that you can't put all
your eggs in one basket
because sending that courtroom and
trying to be hopeful you do put your
eggs in one basket and that basket was a
conviction basket and so once that
basket was was emptied out and there's
no conviction its what do we do now and
so like I said we gathered our thoughts
came back home and and and said okay
this is our next move so I want to in a
second kind of talk about the time since
the trial and Trayvon's death which is
the focus of the book you guys kind of
walk us through those years but before I
kind of move it to a more present day
one thing that's not in the book
that is absent very often is the name of
the man who killed your son George
Zimmerman very often he's referred to as
the killer or the killer of our son we
know he has been in and out of the news
and the intervening years what has there
ever been any contact between you all
and the Zimmerman's is there any you
know do you have any feelings towards
him still what I mean we know he's kind
of made public statements and done
various things but what what if you all
are linked to him forever in this way
for better or for worse obviously the
death of
son is there any is there any feelings
towards George Zimmerman still I still
yeah I I still am at the place where I
was February 6 26 2012 I'm still at that
place that I have anger in me I'd be
less than a man if I told you I you know
my position has changed there is a lot
of anger in me because he's taking
something away from us that we can never
get back as far as and we're linked
together because of that and and the the
only thing that would detach that link
is if our son was here and so I think
that there's a lot of resentment there's
a lot of hurt a lot of pain built up
inside of me what I ever want to sit
down and dialogue with him no absolutely
not because there are emotions I'm a man
first and foremost and there are plenty
of emotions that that are still running
deep in me just because of the love that
I have for my time and that's just a
being a protector of your child I just
don't think that I'll ever get to a
space in my life where I would be able
to sit down and and and ax him why did
you do this he had the chance to explain
why he did it
during the trial and he didn't and so
that was his chance to explain why he
taken two had taken our son away from us
and and so I'm still at the same point
sobrino one point in the book you guys
recounting this might be in a portion
Traci writes but he's recounting an
interview you did with Reverend Al
Sharpton on his show and at the time it
says I think before the trial still when
they're still campaigning to get George
Zimmerman arrested and the Reverend
turns to you and he says are you
determined to hang in there no matter
what and your response to him was until
the day I die I'm a mother and I want
justice for my son and I won't stop
until I received that
what does justice still look like for
you
now I years after the trial and what
does that fight still look like for you
for justice for Trayvon as well as
justice for
all of these other people who have been
given justice for me it's probably a
little different from other people's
justice for me would be Trayvon back
here you know and if I couldn't get
Trayvon back a life was taken certainly
a life should be given and so that's
what justice looks like to me and I
didn't receive that and I know a lot of
people um feel like that you know the
person will get what's coming to them
and I truly believe that but at the same
time it still hurts a great deal that we
have so many evil people in this world
that will shoot and kill somebody
unarmed and then not be that will be
less than honest about what happened and
so it bothers me a great deal you know
it bothers me a great deal but I just
try to put my best foot forward and I
don't you know try to think so much
about who the person was that killed my
son I mean my focus is on so many other
different things and I think that that's
just a distraction when I take my focus
off what I need to be doing for my son
of course know one thing I thought was
interesting was that there were almost
two separate or distinct moments in the
movement that rises up following
Trayvon's death yet the initial kind of
codification this idea of I am Trayvon
the rallies the marches and then it what
became clear around the time of the lack
of a conviction which is the same time
that Jordan Davis's trial is happening
the movie Fruitvale station comes out
telling the story of Oscar Grant from
three years earlier and we see that
codified moving forward all of a sudden
we have Ferguson in Cleveland in
Baltimore and kind of the the beginning
and the conception of the black lives
matter movement more broadly and so I
want to talk about those kind of two
different things because I think that
looking at the specific case of your son
actually helps show us a lot of what
happens in the years following one of
the first things that I want to talk
about though is one of the initial
fights that people were engaged in
around your son's death we're staying
your ground laws this idea that you
these laws that perhaps empowered George
Zimmerman to take Trayvon's life then
perhaps empower him to not be arrested
that night and then also perhaps
empowered him to not be convicted later
on that issue I think has kind of fallen
off of the main conversation that would
seem like a tough battle and it's
unclear you know what the status of
those are a few years removed what do
you think the status is of these kind of
Stand Your Ground laws and the fact that
they're still on the books in so many
states I think that you know the status
stays the same we saw it in the Jordan
Davis case where clearly Jordan was you
know just sitting in the vehicle and and
the individual who took Jordan life just
felt as though you know this you know
they're playing loud music let me just
shoot the car up so to speak and he had
no he really had no explanation why as
to why he did it
only he said he thought that they had a
gun in the car and so his defense was he
was going to try to you stand your
ground and and just just the notion that
this is the mindset of some individuals
that they can shoot and kill young black
and brown boys and without any witnesses
and and can get away with it just
thinking or knowing that they can get
away with it is certainly something that
we have to take a look at what would the
what would the what would it be
what would the momentum of that law be
if you had african-american men going
out shooting young white young men and
saying I was standing my ground I was
fearing for my life it would be a change
in that law so let's not wait until this
starts to happen to make a change to
this law let's change this law it's a
bad law and so we have to look at it
from from different different
perspectives discouraging and all that
that these laws haven't started to
change very discouraging it's very
discouraging just just to know that you
know these laws you know the law doesn't
work I mean how many I'm in how many
cases can you look at and say that this
was an african-american
that used to stand your ground law on a
non african-american it rare that you
know it is rare even with police
brutality you don't see black officers
brutalizing young white man you don't
see it and so definitely there has to be
a revision to repeal or something with
these laws so another thing I thought
was interesting another parallel to some
of the broad protest movement we've seen
is that in this case there was a
combination of older school civil rights
activists who were involved whether it
be the Reverend Sharpton or Reverend
Jackson pastors who were coming in to
provide support but also the birth of a
lot of kind of young activists and
activist collectives groups like the
dream defenders or million hoodies
United for justice that were weren't
people who weren't activists and then
heard the name Trayvon heard of this
story and said I'm dedicating my time in
my life to that that's very similar to
what we saw in these following years in
a Ferguson or Baltimore where you had
people who were old-school civil rights
activists involved but a lot of young
people saying that could have been me
and so I'm going to be in the street
what do you think that says about the
moment we are in right now that we're
seeing young black people as well as
older school black people have been
around the block a few times coming
together in these ways to seek justice
for young men who are being slain I
think a lot of people have always
realized that we have not been treated
fairly well it's just more obvious now
with all the surveillance cameras and
with everybody with camera phones and
and videotapes and everything that it's
it's it's more people are more aware
that it's so current and so now you have
police officers that are being charged
you have officers that are you know
going before a grand jury and those
things didn't happen before and now they
are happening so it's definitely a move
it's just a slow move it's almost like a
Turtles move you know and it you know
when you can see a man being shot in the
back and and nobody is being held
accountable and we can clearly see that
this man was running away I don't
understand what threat that he could
have posed that that
the Walter Scott case absolutely and and
and you know I just don't understand a
lot of the things that's going on but
it's it's definitely bringing the young
people and as well as the older people
closer together and uniting together so
we can make a change and that's what we
definitely need a change because when we
go out and speak as part of our
mentoring program to young young men and
young women they say all the time they
don't feel safe they don't feel safe in
their own community they don't feel safe
in their own country and I remember
growing up I've always felt safe I've
never went outside to play and did not
feel safe our kids I can't feel safe in
their own country
so that says a lot about the direction
we're going in as far as safety and
protection and you know just all of that
is concerned it says a lot about this
country when our children our own
children can't feel safe in their own
community now when we look back at the
last decade the last eight ten years
we've seen the rise of the movement for
black lives a black lives matter
movement and and most people will point
to the death of your son as one of the
that when a catalyst one of the reasons
that this movement was born now I can't
imagine you and you write this that you
couldn't have imagined at the time when
you're getting that first first call
about your son one even the support you
all have received for your for your own
case much less now that this would be a
staying back there this would be a thing
and it strikes me you guys at one point
I forget whose chapter it is refers to
the death of Emmett Till and how in the
fight that Mamie till had to try to both
get justice for her son but how the
death of that young man became one of
the sparks for the civil rights movement
five years removed what do you think of
the legacy of your son's life and of his
death and of the activism that has been
birthed because of it you look at again
groups like the dream defenders a
million hoodies United the group black
lives matter in the phrase black lives
matter
written in response to the failure to
convict your Zimmerman what when you
think about that if you think about that
what what do you what comes to mind well
first and foremost we
we definitely think of Trayvon as a
young man who galvanized this country he
brought he brought many different
cultures together under for one cause
they were fighting for justice and and
and so just to just to know that his
name had structure to do with the the
resurgence of or being a spark for the
new civil rights movement it means a
great deal when you speak of civil
rights there there certainly has been an
abundance of people that have come
before us and put their lives on the
line for us and so just to see how the
new movement is with the young people
getting involved it it certainly has a
different meaning to it because we know
that young people are involved young
people aren't afraid to go out on the
streets and protest and peace and and
voice their opinion this is a this isn't
the the sixties the 50s and the 60s
where we we have to be afraid of our
jobs because we're going protest we have
a voice now and so just to see all the
young people interact intertwine with
the older people and saying that you
know black lives matter and we know that
all lives matter but when we say black
lives matter we look at it in the
content that that's a black life that's
running away from the officer and
getting shot
that's a black life that's getting
choked out in New York for with some
cigarettes that's a black life that's
got his hands up and getting shot on the
street that's a black life that's got
his hands up in this car and get shot
and killed in front of his daughter
that's why we say black lives matter
those lives do matter and we're not you
know and so it's not it's not any other
culture that this is happening to and so
of course yeah all lives matter but when
will this country start realizing that
black lives matter and so just to notice
Trayvon is the new spark to the the
modern-day civil rights it's just an
honor just to be his parents in
that we are part of the new movement now
in addition to in many ways serving as
kind of these elder statesmen and women
of the parents of people who've been
killed you guys do a lot of work through
the Trayvon Martin foundation continuing
his legacy doing mentorship of both
young people as well as the you know the
families of people who have been killed
you talked a little bit about that what
the Trayvon Martin Foundation does and
the work you're continuing to do one of
the things that we're very proud of is
that we do connect with other families
we could make with other mothers and
fathers that are victim of senseless gun
violence and we have what we created as
the circle of mothers and circle of
fathers where we connect with those
families we empower those families we
try to heal those families we come
together and it's not about so much
about Tracy and I it's about us bonding
with those families so that we can heal
together that's just one of the programs
we love talking to the young people
because we know that the young people's
minds are still shapeable you know
sometimes people get older and they
don't want to change their ways but we
know young people minds are still
moldable and-and-and and they listen
they absorb the information and so we
just enjoy talking to the young people
because of that and basically because we
know that they are our future but those
are just some of the things it's about
bringing awareness to gun violence but
it's also about trying to make a
difference in your own community you
know a lot of people want to try to help
the Trayvon Martin foundation and we
love the support but again they need to
basically work in their own community a
difference in their community whether it
be a nonprofit organization or whatever
organization that they work for that
that grassroot so that they can try to
make a difference in their own community
of course well you all have been so
generous with your time today which I
really appreciate and generous with your
notes and your thoughts and your story
what enclosing what should a family
who's out there watching today whether
it be a white familiar black
what should they learn from the lesson
of your family and and from the story
that you guys share I think one of the
main takeaways from from our story it's
the fact that as a family you need to
come together when when you're faced
with adversity and and and learn how to
navigate through that adversity this
book is very therapeutic it's very very
informative as is healing has a lot of
information that goes in-depth on on the
on us as parents not being perfect and
we tell the story how we're not perfect
we tell the story how Trayvon is not
perfect and so just having a glance at
how we looked at everything is what the
book is all about it's a great read and
and we hope that and people go out and
get it of course well Sybrina Fulton
Tracy Martin book is the enduring life
of Trayvon Martin resting power a
parents story of love injustice and the
birth of a movement thank you guys so
much for sharing your time with me today
and thank you for sharing your story
with everybody thank you thank you